[Music]
across europe the pace of vaccination is
increasing
more jabs are going in more doses are
being delivered
there are now four vaccines authorized
for use in the european union
but one of them astrazeneca has had
clearly the roughest ride
rows over possible rare side effects
have led to its use being restricted by
some countries
but the greater anger is about the
company delivering
far fewer doses than the eu ordered
today quietly but combatively
the eu confirmed it was taking legal
action
the terms of the country or some terms
of the contract have not been respected
and the company has not been in a
position
to come up with a reliable strategy to
ensure
the timely delivery of doses what
matters to us
in this case is that we want to make
sure that there is a speedy delivery
of a sufficient number of doses that
european citizens are entitled to
and which have been promised on the
basis of the contract
the company responded quickly and
vehemently
saying astrazeneca has fully complied
with the advanced purchase agreement
with the european commission
and will strongly defend itself in court
we believe any litigation is without
merit and we welcome this opportunity
to resolve this dispute as soon as
possible
but at the heart of this is one rather
woolly expression here's a section
from the european contract with
astrazeneca the first paragraph talks
about the company making
best reasonable efforts to make vaccines
within the eu
the fourth paragraph says that
commitment should include using
factories
within the uk again it says best
reasonable efforts a phrase that is at
once
vague but apparently crucial
litigation takes a long time you've got
to have
a process of everybody producing witness
statements there'll be an enormous
amount of evidence to look at
you're talking about all the emails or
the phone attendance notes
all the whatsapps if those exist all the
documents between the parties
there may be hundreds of statements to
take
it's complicated and it is very time
consuming and it is very expensive
europe was supposed to get 300 million
doses of astrazeneca by the end of june
in fact it will receive a third of that
and none
have been sent from uk factories in
brussels there is
genuine anger and resentment
legal action really offers a quick
solution to commercial rails
and it won't happen here this rancorous
dispute
could yet drag on for years adam parsons
sky news
brussels